hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live Millionen Haushalte in
Deutschland machen sich aktuell Gedanken
über Ihre Heizung spätestens seitdem die
Bundesregierung beschlossen hat dass das
Heizen mit fossilen Brennstoffen ein
Auslaufmodell ist ja und seitdem können
sich die Hersteller von Wärmepumpen vor
Aufträgen kaum noch retten und in dieser
Gemengelage platzt heute die Nachricht
das Viessmann einer der größten
deutschen Heizungsbauer seine
wärmepumpensparte verkauft
es ist eine Zeitenwende für Viessmann
das Familienunternehmen verkauft sein
Kerngeschäft Heizung und Klimatechnik
machen 85% des Umsatzes aus und der
wächst allein im letzten Jahr plus 19%
auf 4 Milliarden Euro
haupttreiber der Wachstumsmarkt
Wärmepumpe politisch gewollt und von der
Regierung gefördert bis 2030 soll die
Zahl der Anlagen auf 6 Millionen steigen
in Deutschland ist Viessmann neben Bosch
Buderus und Vaillant einer der größten
Hersteller das Problem auf den Markt
drängt internationale Konkurrenz vor
allem aus Asien mit großer Erfahrung und
geringeren Kosten gemeinsam mit carrier
will fissmann weiter im wachsenden Markt
mitmischen die Familie Viessmann soll
übrigens größter Einzelaktionär im
US-Unternehmen werden die Heizungsbauer
aus Allendorf wollen auch in Zukunft
mitreden wie sie aussehen soll die
zeitenwände bei Viessmann
ein erfolgreiches
Mittelstandsunternehmen geht also zum
Großteil an einen amerikanischen Konzern
und damit stellt sich die Frage er ist
das ein Ausverkauf der deutschen
Wirtschaft schickt uns eure Meinung
schickt uns eure Fragen gerne in die
Chats posten oder eben eine
E-Mail-Adresse schicken die ihr jetzt
gerade eingeblendet seht wir sprechen
heute Abend mit dem
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Professor
larsfeld und jetzt erstmal mit meiner
zdf-kollegin Valerie Haller an der
Frankfurter Börse hallo Valerie
warum verkauft bis man ausgerechnet
jetzt das Geschäft mit den Wärmepumpen
läuft doch aktuell ja aktuell ist da
irgendwie auch das genau richtige
Stichwort ein wichtiger Punkt ist die
eben schon erwähnte über mächtige
Konkurrenz aus Asien und die ist
natürlich angelockt worden auch durch
Robert havix wärmepumpenplan das sind
Hersteller aus China aus Korea Japan und
die drängen jetzt eben auf den
europäischen Markt und bald mit riesigen
Mengen sogar und da kann eben nur
mithalten wer wirklich groß ist
Viessmann will anscheinend lieber jetzt
aus einer Position der Stärke verkaufen
als später aus der Not heraus wenn
nämlich der große Wettbewerb schon da
ist 12 Milliarden Euro likaria ja für
viessmanns Wärmepumpen auf den Tisch und
das sagt ganz viel aus das ist nämlich
ein Vielfaches des aktuellen Marktwerts
stellt sich trotzdem die Frage hätte es
keine andere Möglichkeit gegeben als den
Verkauf also fürs man hätte sich doch
auch Geld am Markt sorgen können genau
das ist zwar nicht ganz so einfach aber
es hätte schon auch andere Möglichkeiten
gegeben einen Börsengang beispielsweise
oder green Bonds also Anleihen da
Vorteil mit der jetzigen Lösung aber ist
die Marke Viessmann bekommt auf einen
Schlag große neue Produktionsstätten
dazu gewinnt auch Märkte außerhalb
Deutschlands also in den USA
beispielsweise und hat auch mit dem
amerikanischen Unternehmen einen schon
ziemlich finanzstarken Käufer gefunden
einen der übrigens auch gute Chancen hat
im Wettbewerb gegenüber asiatischen
Anbietern zu bestehen also geht es im
Prinzip in einem ersten Schritt jetzt
darum die die riesige gewaltige
Nachfrage im Moment bedienen zu können
das würde Viessmann aktuell alleine
nicht schaffen genau also falls man
hätte sehr viel Geld in die Hand nehmen
müssen und das wäre ganz schwierig
gewesen für Viessmann aber mit dem
Amerikaner zusammen könnte das nun mal
gelingen ja es gibt eine Frage im Chat
oder bzw eine Meinung da heißt es so
lange USA strategischer Partner bleibt
ist es doch in Ordnung in Carrier kann
man ja über Aktien investieren
absolut der Meinung kann man sein
das im Unternehmen Viessmann hat die
Chance mit dem Amerikaner gemeinsam zu
überleben und richtig groß zu werden und
insofern ist das vermutlich erstmal
keinen Schulterschluss gegen den man
prinzipiell etwas haben sollte nein und
Viessmann hat seine Beschäftigten ja
immer als Familienmitglieder bezeichnet
und sehr viel Wert auf seine
Firmentradition gelegt was wird nun aus
dem Jobs was wird davon übrig bleiben
hoffentlich ganz viele sieht doch gar
nicht so schlecht aus für die
Mitarbeiter für die Mitarbeiter und für
den Standort wurden langfristige
Garantien vereinbart und keine
betriebsbedingten Kündigung darf es
geben für die nächsten drei Jahre ja
auch Produktions- und Entwicklung
Standorte für fünf Jahre sind
abgesichert und der Hauptsitz Allendorf
bleibt zehn Jahre gesetzt also das
klingt alles schon nach einem
längerfristigen Engagement von Carrier
ja und die Mitarbeiter der Sparte
bekommen ja außerdem noch 106 Millionen
Euro Sonderprämie für 106 erfolgsjahre
Viessmann das macht rund 10.000 Euro pro
Mitarbeiter und dazu schreibt Lutz
Müller das passt schon wenn man eben
gegen den asiatischen Markt anstinken
will schreibt da braucht man Geld ist
man bleibt mehrheitsanteiler so kommen
sie ans erforderliche Geld stellen wir
noch die Frage was ist mit den anderen
großen deutschen Heizungsbauern wie
stellen Sie sich für die Energiewende
auf also von Vaillant beispielsweise
hört man dass das Unternehmen ohne
Schulterschluss mit einer ausländischen
Firma klar kommen möchte und auch zum
führenden Anbieter von Wärmepumpen
werden will das war ja bislang fismann
außerdem investiert Weinland gerade mit
voller Kraft in Wärmepumpen und auch
Bosch will seine Produktion ausweiten
seine Produktion ausweiten und dennoch
ist Zweifel so ein bisschen angebrachtes
ist schon möglich dass noch andere
deutsche Hersteller zu
Übernahmekandidaten werden denn
asiatische Hersteller sind seit
Jahrzehnten auf Klimaanlagen
spezialisiert die der Wärmepumpen
Technologie sehr sehr ähnelt sie können
in großen Stückzahlen produzieren
deshalb auch günstiger also für die
deutschen Hersteller wird schon relativ
schwierig dagegen anzukommen und jetzt
ist natürlich die Frage die unsere
Userinnen und User möglicherweise am
meisten interessiert nämlich wie wird
sich das alles auf die Preise aus den
aktuell sind Wärmepumpen ja echt teuer
wie nie genau ja wir können davon
ausgehen dass in den nächsten Jahren
viele Wärmepumpen von Anbietern eben wie
gesagt auch aus Asien auf den deutschen
Markt geschwemmt werden und die
Hersteller dort können eben in großen
Stückzahlen produzieren und meist auch
recht günstig also über kurz oder lang
dürften Wärmepumpen bei uns schon
deutlich günstiger werden also
Wärmepumpen werden günstiger da bleibt
er nur noch die große Frage ob man auch
jemanden findet der sie einbaut dass
dann wiederum ein anderes Thema vielen
Dank Valerie an der Frankfurter Börse
tschüss
also ein deutscher Hersteller verkauft
seinen Kerngeschäft ins Ausland und das
ist in der Vergangenheit nicht immer gut
gegangen wie jetzt Jan Schüssler zeigt
verliert Deutschland die nächste
Schlüsselindustrie bei der Diskussion um
die Wärmepumpe fühlen sich viele an die
Solarindustrie erinnert was war passiert
Ende der 90er und Anfang der 2000er
boomt die deutsche Solarindustrie die
Branche wächst schnell und vor allem aus
China steigen Mitbewerber ein deutsche
Expertise wird übernommen und in Asien
entstehen riesige Fabriken zur
Herstellung von Solarzellen und Modulen
in denen günstiger produziert wird
außerdem fallen in Deutschland nach und
nach Subventionen Weg nur einige Jahre
nach dem Boom war die einstige deutsche
vorzeigeindustrie nach China abgewandert
und zwar nicht nur die Produktion
sondern auch Forschung und Entwicklung
heute dominiert China den Markt für
Fotovoltaikanlagen drei Viertel der
weltweit produzierten Module kommen aus
China auch Deutschland ist Abhängig rund
87% der nach Deutschland eingeführten
Anlagen kamen 2022 aus China in einem
Gesamtwert von 3,1 milliar den Euro
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck hat sich
heute gegen solche Vergleiche gewährt
deutsche Firmen seien aus dem Markt
gedrängt worden bei Solarpaneele im
asiatischen Raum günstiger produziert
werden
und damit darf ich Sie ganz herzlich bei
ZDF heute live begrüßen Professor
larsfeld guten Abend
guten Abend grüße sie ich schaue direkt
in den Chat da gibt es einige Kommentare
einen User schreibt auf Youtube das
erinnert mich sehr an den Ausverkauf der
solar- und Windkraftindustrie nach China
Windkraft und solaranlagenbauer sind das
beste Beispiel wir haben tolle Technik
bauen und verdienen machen andere was
wir auch gerade eben im Beitrag gesehen
haben haben sie dann Dejavue
nein ich habe das nicht erwünscht ich
habe bei der Subventionierung der
Solarindustrie von vornherein
Probleme gehabt also wenn man die
Industrie mit solchen massiven
Subventionen versucht aufzubauen und
dann auch im Land zu halten da muss man
sich nicht wundern dass irgendwann auf
der Welt jemand aufkommt der eben doch
noch deutlich günstiger produzieren kann
und Solarpaneele sind es unbedingt nicht
unbedingt auch die Hochtechnologie die
waren anderen Bereichen haben das sieht
bei Wärmepumpen durchaus anders aus und
ich würde eher die Investition von
Carrier so interpretieren dass der
amerikanische Investor viel größere
Chancen sieht im europäischen Markt und
deswegen mit Viessmann zusammen gehen
möchte
Stichwort Chancen worin liegen denn die
Chancen aus deutscher Sicht für diesen
Deal wo würden diese Idee sehen
nun die Familie Viessmann ist einerseits
weiter beteiligt hat eben auch ein
entsprechendes Aktienpaket bei Carrier
realisiert oder wird es realisiert haben
mit diesem Deal die Beschäftigten
bleiben in Deutschland und werden hier
auch ordentliche Einkommen erzielen
können und für den Markt bei dem auf dem
ist ja darauf ankommt möglichst bald
möglichst viele Wärmepumpen zu bekommen
ist es ein gutes Signal dass die
Produktion eben mit einem so großen
Investor aus den USA
weiter vorangehen kann in größeren
Stückzahlen produziert werden kann das
bedeutet alleine von diesen Stückzahlen
her dass
Kostensenkungen zustande kommen wir
reden von Skalen Erträgen Skalen
Vorteilen weil man eben viel größeren
Stückzahlen produziert und das bedeutet
auch dass die Preise tendenziell sinken
werden und davon werden eben die
Verbraucher profitieren schau mal auf
die Gefahren da gibt es die Sorge dass
die Interessen des Standorts Deutschland
aus dem Blick geraten könnten am teilen
Sie die
ich teile im Moment wenige sorgen mit
dieser Investition von Carrier so weit
in Deutschland weiter produziert wird
und davon ist gegenseitig ja auszugehen
gelten die deutschen Standards und sie
gibt überhaupt kein Problem und keine
Sorge dass wir da sagen müssten die der
amerikanische Investor das amerikanische
Unternehmen macht uns irgendwelche
Probleme was man einfach auf Dauer dann
sehen muss ist wie stark dieser
Wärmepumpenmarkt sich dann auch
längerfristig entwickeln wird wenn erst
einmal die große Nachfrage bedient ist
aber das ist noch Zukunftsmusik und dann
werden wir auch sehen wie der Standort
Allendorf in Zukunft dann da stehen wird
es gibt eine Frage aus dem Chat von Sven
er fragt muss den Deal auch noch die
Bundesregierung zustimmen oder gilt das
nur für kritische Infrastruktur wie
helfen und Flughäfen
das gilt vor allen Dingen zunächst
einmal von der Höhe der Investition das
heißt der Investor muss mehr als 25
Prozent des der Anteil eines
Unternehmens des Eigenkapitals
Unternehmens tragen das ist hier der
Fall also insofern gibt es eine Prüfung
nach im Außenwirtschaftsrecht allerdings
sind die dann weiteren Hürden die Frage
nach der kritischen Infrastruktur
beispielsweise in diesem Fall eigentlich
nicht anwendbar man muss schon davon
ausgehen dass die Investition zustande
kommt und äh Viessmann mit Carrier
zusammen gehen kann bleiben wir noch mal
bei der Politik jetzt hat
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck ja gesagt
der Deal soll dem Standort Deutschland
dienen wie kann er das denn überhaupt
sicherstellen
sicherstellen kann er das nicht es ist
dann am Ende ja schon so dass eine ganze
Reihe von Unternehmen ihre Wärmepumpen
in Deutschland anbieten werden und wir
werden ja schließlich auch froh sein
wenn in den großen Stückzahlen die wir
in Deutschland aber auch in Europa für
diese Technologie benötigen wenn diese
großen Stückzahlen hier auch angeboten
werden können was dann wirklich an
Produktion hier stattfindet dass hängt
eben auch von Kostenstrukturen ab von
Fertigkeiten von der Fähigkeit hoch
qualitative Produkte herzustellen da
auch was Forschung und Entwicklung an
betrifft immer wieder
vorneweg zu laufen also
bessere innovativere Produkte zu
produzieren das geht ja nicht nur für
das Thema Wärmepumpen oder
klimatechnologie ganz allgemein sondern
es gilt für alle Produktion die in
Deutschland stattfindet und da wird man
auch von Seiten der Investoren fragen
müssen wie sieht die Standortqualität
aus darüber kann man dann weiter
diskutieren aber das hat nichts mit dem
Fall diesmal zu tun
sie beraten ja unter anderem auch den
Finanzminister in Wirtschaftsfragen und
er hat jetzt davor gewarnt dass sich die
Politik eben zu sehr auf eine
Technologie konzentrieren und fixieren
könnte
setzt die Regierung zu sehr auf
Wärmepumpen
es ist meines Erachtens ein Problem wenn
man nicht technologieoffen operiert zwar
wünscht sich wünschen sich Unternehmen
häufig klare Vorgaben vor allen Dingen
weil sie dann eben auch die Hoffnung
haben dass es an der ein oder anderen
Stelle auch noch mal eine Subvention
gibt aber die technologieoffenheit sorgt
eben dafür dass man im Zeitablauf eben
auch andere Technologien zum zugekommen
ist und eben nicht nur auf das was man
sich heute vorstellen kann an
Technologie setzt das ist der der
richtige Ansatz die technologieoffenheit
ist entscheidend und das wird werden wir
in den kommenden Jahren entsprechend
nutzen müssen
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen dass
Wärmepumpen der falsche Ansatz ist das
ist von heute aus der heutigen
Perspektive betrachtet in Hinblick auf
die Klimaneutralität ein richtiger
Schritt trotzdem ist es notwendig die
technologieoffenheit auch in diesem in
diesen Marktsegmenten zu bewahren
es gibt hier noch einige Fragen im Chat
zu diesem Deal ähm
eine Frage eine rechtliche Frage von
Michael menneyer wenn Viessmann und
unter ein amerikanisches Dach kommt
welches Mitbestimmungsrecht gilt dann
deutsches oder US-amerikanisches
und da bin ich überfragt ich bin kein
Jurist ich bin Ökonom ich kann Ihnen
diese arbeitsrechtliche Frage nicht
beantworten und schon gar nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit dann machen wir doch
direkt weiter mit der nächsten Frage
da schauen wir sind die Wärmepumpen
jetzt nur für den Heizungsmarkt relevant
oder wofür könnten die Produkte noch
relevant sein
und sie haben schwierige Fragen also die
technische Frage bin auch kein Ingenieur
will ich Ihnen auch lieber nicht
beantworten ja wir haben anspruchsvolle
User hier im Chat wir sehen das schon
aber super
schau mal vielleicht finde ich noch eine
naja es gibt Kritik tatsächlich auch ne
ähm da geht es darum dass eben
energieintensive Betriebe ins Ausland
gehen Technik wird ins Ausland gefragt
verlagert und Forschung ist in
Deutschland auch nicht mehr aktuell
würden sie das so unterschreiben diese
Meinung von Mark
ich sehe das Risiko dass die
energieintensive Wirtschaft abwandern
könnte ich sehe auch das Problem dass
wir in der ganzen in ganz
unterschiedlichen Dimensionen ein
Kostenproblem für die deutsche
Wirtschaft haben wir haben ja nicht nur
die hohen Energiekosten deswegen
Stichwort energieintensive Wirtschaft
sondern wir haben auch relativ hohe
Arbeitskosten und
Lohnzusatzkosten wir haben eine relativ
hohe Steuerbelastung für Unternehmen
egal ob sie nun Kapitalgesellschaften
der Personengesellschaften sind also im
Großen und Ganzen haben sich die
Rahmenbedingungen in Deutschland klar
verschlechtert eine intensive
Regulierung liegt vor und diese
Regulierungsdichte Hemd eben auch
Innovation mich hat schon sehr gewundert
dass wir mit der Nachricht des biontech
die nächste Welle ihrer Innovation seine
Innovationstätigkeit in
Großbritannien realisiert im Vereinigten
Königreich realisiert das ist da kein
Aufschrei gegeben hat denn was letztlich
den Ausschlag gegeben hat war die zu
hohe regulierungsintensität die ist eben
nicht so leicht macht Forschung
umzusetzen und wenn man in bestimmten
Bereichen schnell sein will um eine
Führungsposition im Markt einzunehmen
wie das bayernthek ja versucht dann hat
man ein Problem also wir müssen dringend
an diese unterschiedlichen Kosten Blöcke
an und darüber nachdenken wie wir hier
bessere Rahmenbedingungen für
Investitionen und Innovation schaffen
können bleiben wir mal beim Thema
Rahmenbedingungen bis man hat ja eine
Tradition als Familienunternehmen und da
gibt es eine Umfrage vom Verband der
Familienunternehmer die würde ich mir
gerne kurz mit ihnen anschauen und zwar
über die Hälfte der Befragten also 56%
würde ein Unternehmen künftig in einem
anderen Land als Deutschland aufbauen
und
47% der befragten Unternehmen denken ein
bis zweimal im Jahr daran Ihr
bestehendes Unternehmen zu verkaufen 16%
jede Woche und immerhin sechs Prozent
jeden Tag sogar würden Sie sagen
dass es vielen so geht dass der
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland immer
unattraktiver wird
der Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland ist
unattraktiver geworden bei
Familienunternehmen kommt noch ein
zusätzliches Problem hinzu das ist die
Nachfolge und die Frage wie kann man die
Nachfolge regeln wir haben ja angesichts
der vor uns liegenden demografischen
Entwicklung und der
arbeitskräftesituation die dadurch
entsteht eben auch die Schwierigkeit wie
kommen wir da weiter voran und das geht
am Ende auch für die Nachfolge
Problematik wenn beispielsweise
überhaupt keine Kinder da sind also von
daher kann ich ganz gut verstehen dass
in dieser Momentaufnahme die wir jetzt
haben mit den veränderten
Kostenstrukturen einerseits der der
höheren der geringeren Attraktivität der
höheren Unattraktivität des Standards
Deutschland eine Reihe von Unternehmen
sagen würden wir sind ja auf dem
absteigenden Ast aber dem kann man
entgegenwirken indem man sich doch
wirklich noch mal Gedanken darüber macht
was macht Standortqualität aus und hier
haben wir einiges an
Verbesserungspotenzial und da würde ich
gerne noch mal mit ihnen ein bisschen in
die Tiefe gehen also die Unternehmen
beklagen sich über Bürokratie schlechte
Infrastruktur Fachkräfte Mangel und
Experten sagen ist wird noch viel mehr
fismanns geben auch in anderen Bereichen
vielleicht konkrete Punkte was muss ich
aus ihrer Sicht ändern
und wenn sie bei den Themen die Sie
angesprochen haben Fachkräftemangel das
ist ein Thema dass ich angesichts der
Demographie kaum lösen lassen wird wir
haben weiterhin Schwierigkeiten mit
diesem demografischen Übergang
Zuwanderung kann das nicht vollständiger
setzen auch wenn wir jetzt eine
liberalere Migrationspolitik haben
sollten man muss sich in der Hinsicht
also was diese Dimension Fachkräfte oder
Arbeitskräftemangel ganz allgemein
gesprochen anbetrifft dann schon auch
Gedanken darüber machen wie schaffen wir
es denn das bestehende
Arbeitskräftepotenzial zu erhöhen dafür
zu sorgen dass er weniger Teilzeitarbeit
haben dafür zu sorgen dass die Menschen
auch in ihrer Lebensarbeitszeit bereit
sind mehr dem Arbeitsmarkt stärker dem
Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung zu stehen
wenn Sie das Thema Infrastruktur
ansprechen das diskutieren wir schon
lange drüber wir haben in verschiedenen
Dimensionen eine deutlich schlechtere
Infrastruktur dieser Ausbau muss voran
gebracht werden das ist nicht einfach
eine eine Frage des Geldes wie wir das
seit einigen Jahren diskutieren es ist
vor allen Dingen auch eine Frage der
Regulierung und da spielt dann das
dritte Thema dass sie ansprechen hinein
die höheren Bürokratiekosten entstehen
ja vor allen Dingen weil wir immer
komplexere Rechtssysteme bekommen haben
und die unterschiedlichen Rechtsbereiche
greifen häufig auch noch so ineinander
dass die restriktionswirkung verstärkt
wird hier muss man einsetzen also es
geht schon auch um Regulierungsfragen
und ich finde schon dass die
Regulierungen auf dem Prüfstand müssen
und man genauer fragen muss was ist
davon nötig was brauchen wir wie setzen
wir die Prioritäten damit mehr
Innovation und mehr Investitionen
stattfinden können damit haben sie die
Frage von Puro auch beantwortet warum
verbessert man dann die
Standortbedingungen nicht eben z.B
weniger Bürokratie jetzt schlagen wir
zum Schluss gleich letzte Frage noch mal
den Bogen zur Energiewende ist es denn
vielleicht am Ende des Tages auch so
dass die Energiewende die ja jetzt sehr
ehrgeizig von der Regierung
vorangetrieben wird die deutschen
Heizungsbauer auch ein Stück weit
überfordert oder müssen die sich auf den
Vorwurf gefallen lassen dass sie die
ganze Sache auch ein Stück weit
verschlafen haben
ich glaube nicht dass man den deutschen
Heizungsbauern vorwerfen kann sie hätten
etwas verschlafen wir haben ja gerade
auch im Falle Viessmann feststellen
können dass die Wärmepumpentechnologie
die Viessmann bereithält das ist im
wesentlicher Teil des
Viessmann schon Geschäfts eben auch
einem hohen technologischen Niveau
stattfinden sonst würden auch die 12
Milliarden nicht gezahlt werden die sind
ja dann doch eigentlich ja eine sehr
üppige Investitionen wenn man sich die
Marktkapitalisierung genauer anschaut
also vor dem Hintergrund würde ich das
verschlafen nicht behaupten wollen das
kann man nicht in das würde ich in Frage
stellen diese diese Interpretation was
man sagen muss ist wenn so viel mehr an
Wärmepumpen gefordert wird dann haben
Anbieter größere Anbieter aufgrund der
Skalen Vorteile der Tatsache dass sie
mit hohen Stückzahlen produzieren können
einen Kostenvorteil und diesen
Kostenvorteil den Spielen sie dann auf
dem Markt entsprechend aus durch
niedrigere Preise und
da ist es nur logisch sich eben mit
einem großen Anbieter wie Carrier
zusammen zu tun und den europäischen
Markt auf diese Art und Weise dann
besser zu bedienen und wir werden
beobachten wie das weitergeht Herr Feld
ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich für ihre
Einschätzungen vielen Dank schönen Abend
noch tschüss ich danke ihnen danke danke
für die
da war er schon weg und damit wollen wir
uns auch für heute Abend verabschieden
vielen Dank fürs dabei sein und fürs
Mitmachen bis bald tschüss